are you doing today
I'm doing good first of all congrats on
the movie I really enjoyed it and also
all the kids in the theater where I saw
it
we're just silent which means that they
were all into it no it totally if
they're not if they if they keep talking
means they have no interest on the film
two points yeah just so I guess the
first thing is what do you think would
surprise people to learn about the
making of small foot hmm I mean I guess
a common misconception that people have
especially about movies is that we're
all in the room together reading these
scenes together whereas mostly actors
are in a booth by themselves and like
maybe listening to audios of other
actors or maybe our director character
Patrick reading the other lines with us
so that's really funny because even as
an actor you see scenes piece together
and it's hilarious because you don't
exactly know what the other person said
or like what changes have happened I'm
often making animated movies there's
dramatic changes was there anything
dramatic that changed with your
character plot my characters consistency
you know minor minor line changes cool
um for everyone today I'm gonna be
playing get to know your small foot cast
member so here we go what TV show would
you love to guest spot on I've had the
great British baking show heard that
from a few people yeah really not today
at this junket but I've asked this
question do you have a favorite sci-fi
or fantasy film sci-fi or fantasy film
okay I'm thinking I'm thinking I'm
thinking I really got to put it out
there in case you know you're searching
for that role I have to oh my gosh this
is difficult
you can see the Marvel movies yeah okay
what's my favorite
I'd have to say Black Panther right now
is there anything that you collect
I collect um collect watches I used to
collect seashells until I lost my
collection you buy an airline on that
run no it was actually fun story they
were using my seashell collection for a
movie I was in when I was 12 and we got
the seashells back the box had broke
like so that was really sad
I collect what else do I collect from
around the world
I really collect gifts from my brother's
okay you know completely um is there a
TV show that you've watched all the way
through more than once yes um Parks and
Rec of course Ouran High School Host
Club watch like five different times
um house lawn Order SVU watch it so many
times
criminal intent one order criminal
intent right so you're Eric urinal
you're one of the people that are tuning
in each week on Law & Order
Oh first you're a white collar shirt
like boomer was very good on that show
anything on the ion channel cuz it's
positively entertaining right do you do
other things but watch TV oh for sure
I'm a podcast person got it like the
amount of TV that I'm sweet enough is
even surprising cuz all I do are listen
to podcasts I started because I was
obsessed with old detective shows like X
minus one or dragnet and all of that so
I found a podcast that like had those
old replays and then I started expanding
into this American life I saw I got to
see Ira Glass in concert exciting like
top-10 moment of life um I already have
to rap but I'm just gonna say that's
awesome yeah Congrats on the movie for
real thank you so much
you